Washington has been in near limbo all
day mesmerized by the promise that the
now-famous House Intelligence Committee
memo will be released at any moment any
second we don't know when it turns out
at this point all we know for certain
about the memo is that it's four pages
long it was compiled by Intel Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez and as of tonight
remains classified and hidden from
public view according to some who have
read it the memo exposes shocking
misconduct by our intelligence and law
enforcement agencies during the 2016
election including spying on Americans
for political purposes we can't confirm
any of that like pretty much everyone
else we have not seen the document but
the charges are strong enough to shake
public faith in some of our most
important public institutions and the
only way to fix that is to release the
memo so the rest of us can see the
evidence and decide for ourselves what
it amounts to that's how democracies
work it seems like an obvious solution
in fact it's the only solution and yet
for some reason the prospect of
transparency has triggered panic in the
Democratic Party and among its
praetorian guard in the media just a
year ago the Washington Post for example
adopted the Pampas and yet indisputably
true slogan democracy dies in darkness
just this week that paper dismissed the
Congressional memo as quote a hyper
partisan attempt to discredit Muller of
course the post would have no way of
knowing that they haven't seen the memo
they don't want you to see it either
how did democracy dies in darkness
become some things are best kept secret
it turns out that when transparency
hurts Democrats the media opposed
transparency remember wooden CNN's Chris
Cuomo warned viewers they would be
breaking the law simply by reading John
Podesta is leaked emails well needless
to say most government bureaucrats agree
with the media on this as the onion put
it today FBI warns the Republican memo
could undermine faith in massive
unaccountable secret government agencies
no surprise there most people everywhere
would rather avoid accountability if
it's at all possible the federal
government's transparency caucus has
always been notably small the question
is are there legitimate reasons to
oppose releasing the memo reasons have
nothing to do with craven media cheer
for Democrats or with Adam ships career
aspirations only two legitimate reasons
come to mind are the contents of the
memo provably false and therefore
libelous and would releasing the memo in
peril national security
those are real questions and so far the
answer to both appears to be no in other
words there is no excuse for withholding
this document from the public claims to
the contrary our partisan barking and
you ought to ignore them